Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going to
explain a Japanese psychological thriller film
called “Tales of the unusual: washing machine.”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
Hashimoto is a middle-aged man living in Ginza,
Tokyo. He is struggling financially after being
laid off from his job. One morning, he goes to the
laundry place to clean his clothes. After loading
up the dryer, he wishes he could enjoy a can of
beer. Something drops inside the dryer and makes
a loud noise. On checking, he finds a can of beer
inside. At first, Hashimoto believes that someone
might have left it there but he is confused
when the beer turns out to be chilled. The old
cleaner of the place casually tells him that the
dryer fulfills everyone’s wish. Hashimoto thinks
he is a lunatic and ignores him but the man walks
closer and declares he is telling the truth. After
he leaves, Hashimoto drinks the beer while waiting
for his clothes to be cleaned. A girl enters the
room and loads up her laundry. Hashimoto has never
had the courage to talk to women. Because of this,
he has been single his entire life. He nervously
scoots to the end of the seat to make space
for her. The girl sits beside him and starts a
conversation. She has noticed him in the laundry
several times before and has developed a crush on
him. Hashimoto, on the other hand, is oblivious
of her efforts to start a conversation.
He throws the now empty can to the trash bin
but it lands on the floor. When he gets up to
retrieve it, Kondo starts to cry. An uncomfortable
Hashimoto asks her what is wrong when she
reveals that she interviewed for forty companies
but didn’t get selected in any. To make her feel
better, he tells her that he was also laid off
from his job. He thinks that the fact she was able
to interview for so many companies is amazing.
This means she has the most experience in
interviews than any of the candidates she
meets. The girl starts to look at her situation
differently after the chat. She thanks him for
being nice even though she is just a stranger.
Following that, he brings his clothes out and
wishes her farewell. As he is leaving, the girl
introduces herself as Kondo. After the encounter,
Hashimoto returns home happily. At night, his
mother calls him, informing him that his father
has been hospitalized. They need a total of three
hundred thousand yen to pay for the hospital bill.
The responsibility falls upon Hashimoto but he
neither has a job, nor savings. Yet, he promises
to send them the money and visit them as soon as
possible. He returns to the laundry place the very
next morning. He is almost sure that the old man
from yesterday was bluffing, but he still wants to
test the theory. He stands in front of the dryer
and asks for three hundred thousand yen.
After waiting for a few seconds, he realizes how
stupid the idea is. He is about to leave when
suddenly, a bundle of money appears inside the
dryer. Hashimoto brings it out, still unable to
believe it actually worked. The bundle has
exactly the amount of money he asked for.
As he tries to walk away with it, he sees the
beer can from yesterday disappearing. The old
man informs him that the things he receives
from the dryer will disappear within a day so
he should be careful. Hashimoto thanks him and
rushes outside. He happens to bump into Kondo
yet again who tells him she got invited for a
second interview for the first time in her life.
Hashimoto congratulates her and gets a call from
his mother yet again. Kondo hears him talk and
finds out about his sick father. After chatting
for a while, Hashimoto leaves to quickly send
the money before it disappears.
Following that, he returns to the
laundry place again. He plans to use it
to solve all his problems in life. Hence,
this time, he asks for a nice suit that he can
wear for job interviews. He goes to interview for
several companies the entire day. However, when he
returns home, he gets letters from the companies,
informing him that he hasn’t been selected in any.
The suit also disappears in front of his eyes.
After the failure Hashimoto realizes, now that
he has an unlimited source of money, he shouldn’t
waste his time looking for a job. Instead, he
should enjoy his life to the fullest. So, the
next morning, he makes sure no one is around and
wishes for a confident and beautiful girl. He adds
that the girl should be envied by everyone, as
beautiful as a model. One such girl steps out of
the dryer, mesmerizing Hashimoto with her beauty.
He walks closer and asks her to come to his house.
The girl, however, slaps him in the face for
being so bold on the first date. She storms out
of the place as Hashimoto is left stunned.
After learning from his mistake, he asks for a
sweet and attentive girlfriend who is pretty and
who loves him very much. A beautiful girl with the
said qualities steps out of the dryer. The girl
excitedly agrees to go out on a date with him,
much to his relief. He takes her shopping and uses
the money from the dryer to buy her everything she
wants. It turns out that the humans created by
the dryer do not have any idea of their origin
and think that they are real people. At the end of
the day, Hashimoto brings her back to his house.
Even then, he is scared of getting close to
her so they agree to talk the entire night.
On looking at Hashimoto’s palm the girl comments
that his life is very short. He is taken aback
by the comment but decides to ignore it. In the
morning, he finally gathers enough courage to
lean in to kiss her but she disappears right
before he can. The only things left are the
clothes and jewelry he bought for her.
Hashimoto felt a connection with the girl
but he is not sad about the disappearance now
that he can get as many girlfriends as he wants.
Starting that day, he comes to the laundry place
every morning and gets a new girlfriend, each
with a different personality. He takes them on
extravagant dates and buys them expensive jewelry
with the money from the dryer. He is living his
life to the fullest with his newfound source.
One day, he is on a date with one of such
girlfriends when Kondo sees him. She gets jealous
and curiously follows them to a jewelry store.
On seeing Hashimoto buying the girl an expensive
ring, she is furious. She is also confused as to
how he gained so much money in just a few days.
When Hashimoto goes to the laundry place again
that night, he runs into Kondo. She asks him about
the money to which he claims he won a lottery. She
also finds out that he is in a casual relationship
with the girl she saw earlier. Kondo starts to
believe that the girl is spoiling him and is
using him for his money. Hashimoto is no longer
the man she liked. He dismisses her concerns
and walks away with another bundle of money.
Following the encounter, he goes on another date
to an expensive restaurant and brings his new
girlfriend to the roof. He also gives her a ring
and tells her that he loves her. She disappears
after a few minutes leaving only the ring behind.
As usual, Hashimoto keeps the ring
with him and continues about his day.
Since he has been asking for innocent girls till
now, he decides to go for a change and asks for
someone who is seductive. One such girl steps out
of the dryer, making him nervous. As they flirt,
Kondo arrives there and spies on them. She sees
him giving her several rings that he has collected
by now. He gets a call from his mother and asks
her to keep quiet for a few seconds. When she
doesn't, he has to step out of the room. Kondo
takes the opportunity to talk to the girl and ask
her what she has done to the old Hashimoto. When
the girl laughs at her and asks her to go away,
an enraged Kondo tries to snatch her rings. In the
meantime, Hashimoto talks to his mother who tells
him that his father might need an operation. More
than the money, the parents need him to visit them
but he has been too busy with his girlfriends
to care. After the call, the old man approaches
Hashimoto, saying that he has forgotten to tell
him one important thing about the dryer.
He says that the person who comes out of
the dryer will also disappear in a day.
Hashimoto laughs at him, claiming he already knew
that. Inside, the girls continue to wrestle to
get the rings. In the end, the new girl leaves
thinking that Hashimoto was cheating on her.
He returns to see Kondo crying and hoping that he
would turn into the guy she first met a few days
ago. Because of the wish, Hashimoto is teleported
into the dryer. His clothes have changed into what
he was wearing when he first met Kondo. He soon
realizes that the dryer has granted Kondo’s wish.
Since he came out of the dryer, he has only a day
to live. The TV shows the news about thousands of
yen going missing from a jewelry shop. At the
end of the movie, Hashimoto falls to the ground
while Kondo watches him in confusion.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.